and that's gonna lineup's gonna face uh
matt harvey you're working on a two-game
losing streak
really hasn't pitched that dreadful
but not a lot of run support so any runs
he gives up seems to be very meaningful
singled his final at bat popped up
richie martin's right there one down
[Applause]
and this one a shot to short off the
chest and bobbled and solaire is going
to reach
so martin made an error last night makes
an error here in the first inning hard
hit ball and the braves have their first
base runner brings up freddie freeman
jeff riding a hot streak at the plate as
you know 14 hits three homers in his
last six games he's been incredible no
score just underway
and a bullet the other way freeman takes
what the oriole defense gives him a
two-out hit and the braves have a first
inning threat first and second
one out for austin reilly and a
seven-game hitting streak for freeman
and riley shoots it into left field to
base it solaire had to hold up and the
braves have him loaded just out of reach
of richie martin in short austin riley
has his second hit of the series and
jeff the braves offense has them loaded
with one out army from the belt 2-2 on
the way and he got him two down there's
a good one
finally gets on top of it finally gets
the good tilt
and it appears it's going to stay in the
middle plate and then just dive bombs to
the outside corner
[Applause]
bounce down to third franco up with it
gets the force at second and the braves
lead them leave them loaded nice job by
harvey getting out of trouble drew's
eight and three on the year and he's
been pitching very well as you see over
his last 13. and here's ryan matt castle
last night was the first time
he hit second in the order this year
he's
back there again tonight
3-2 fastball hit well way back left
field
it is gone into the oriole bullpen ryan
montcastle gave it a ride
and the orioles are on top for ryan home
run number 21.
and this ball just blistered
it is smoke
see him choked up with a one-two pitch
and chased that in the dirt and that
will retire the side
one ball two strikes
and swing and a miss chased one out of
the zone smiley has four strikeouts two
in each of the first two innings
and now the ninth place hitter richie
martin's coming up
one nothing baltimore the lead a first
inning run
and now the one-two pitch
he swung and missed boy baltimore really
expanded the zone in that inning smiley
strikes out his fifth man
so tour on two route here's dansby
line driving to right center field that
is down for a base hit that's gonna tie
the game here comes freddie the third
they're gonna wave him the relay won't
be made dansby swanson on the first
pitch doubles to right center and the
braves have their first lead peterson
leading off the fourth inning dansby
swanson's double the difference
and peterson hits one high in the air
deep toward right that one's got a
chance that one is gone first row homer
for jack peterson to extend the lead
jack with his 15th of the year 3-1
braves
anthony santander struck out his only
at-bat
that's hammered way back down the line
and left and gone
there it is
first homer of the year from the right
side
santander hits six as a left-hand hitter
he got a long one here
and the lead is cut to 3-2 good way to
beat the ship wouldn't you say and urias
will bet
that ball hit well
way back ramona rios and we've got
back-to-back jacks
first santander
now aureus number seven for him and this
game's tied at three austin riley a
single in two trips
riley hits one a mile toward left he got
a hangar riley will not miss it it's in
the stands and the braves are back in
front the two out homers are coming fast
and furious in baltimore tonight 27th
for riley in the braves lead four to
three well half of the sixth inning with
the braves up four to three
five homers in this game three by the
orioles two by the braves mancini's got
a base hit line drive into left field to
get the orioles started in the sixth
we'll take that
all over 92 in the middle of the play
and now severino the batter a catcher
he's singled in the second he's also
flied out to center
and a shot hit to left but right at
duvall
two quick outs after the two strike hit
fly ball hit deep toward left but not
deep enough duvall is there and you said
it jeff rodriguez will give up a hit
then he gives up three fly balls and the
braves hold serve in the six four three
atlanta full cop pitch
he got him
and a good one
3-2 pitch
struck him out
oh he got pitched too
back to the next strikeout
fastball when he was looking for
something else and then all of a sudden
three and two i have no idea
great pitch great pitching mullins the
a-l hits leader coming into this series
facing a one-two pitch
and he struck him out nancy is retired
four in a row
he just carved up mullins with that
breaking ball jeff he'll turn things
over now to luke jackson who's on for
the 53rd time
another ground ball riley at the back
scoops and fires on the run good play
well i like that slider i think you can
get a swing and miss with a good one
he did and jackson takes care of
severino baltimore threatens they can't
tie it up 4-3 atlanta through eight in
game two here it is
ozzie with a shot to right field down
for a base in wanted at bat helmet
flying he's on his way to second vote is
on his way to third and 11 pitch at bat
for ozzy all bees and the braves a great
chance to add on that was amazing
fly ball center field is going to be
deep enough you figure mullins is there
settles under vote the tag he's coming
home tagging at second heading to third
as albies and solaire with another huge
late inning rbi
one in miami against alcantara one here
in baltimore to extend the lead it's a
5-3 game what a great attack anthony
homered in the fourth inning and then
marias followed him up with a home run
back to back
high flying ball it's deep way back and
out of here anthony santander
second homer of the game
gets the orioles within one smith ahead
0-1 braves and out away from another
victory on the road
i fly ball to left duvall is going to
catch it and the braves have won it an
8-0 road trip so far the braves have
their 67th win
[Applause]